concernés par cette probable future
taxation facebook la plateforme de mark
zuckerberg suspend les comptes de donald
trump pour deux ans l'ex président des
états unis ne pourra donc plus
s'exprimer sur le réseau social jusqu'en
une sanction annoncée via communiqué la
mesure entre dans une stratégie plus
strictes à l'égard des responsables
politiques qui seront désormais
sanctionnés comme n'importe quel autre
utilisateur la correspondance à
washington signé tom abonnés la
condition pour le retour de l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche sur la
plateforme que les risques pour la
sécurité du public et disparus selon les
termes avancée par le réseau social une
décision qui fait suite aux événements
du 6 janvier dernier au capitole et dont
facebook tient donald trump en partie
responsable lui sont notamment reproché
des publications posté ce jour-là est
considéré par facebook comme étant des
marques de soutien à des actions
violentes
c'est d'ailleurs à la suite de cette
date que le réseau social a décidé de
revoir sa politique de modération
désormais les élus et les candidats à
une élection ne bénéficieront plus de
passe-droits et devront respecter les
mêmes règles que l'ensemble des
utilisateurs
les équipes de facebook planchait depuis
plusieurs semaines sur la
proportionnalité de la sanction à
imposer
il existe désormais un barème de
punition alors d'une suspension d'un
mois à deux ans cette suspension
concerne également instagram propriété
du groupe facebook compte à twitter
l'entreprise avait déjà décidé il ya
plusieurs mois de suspendre de manière
permanente le compte de l'ancien
président cette nouvelle politique des
géants du numérique est interprétée de
façon différente selon le camp politique
côté démocrate on estime que c'est
tardif et pas forcément assez ferme
côté républicain on crie à la censure
par des entreprises privées
en ce qui concerne donald trump il s'est
insurgé peu après ces annonces de
facebook contre ce qu'il qualifie d'
insulte aux 75 millions de personnes qui
ont voté pour lui il ne devrait pas
avoir le droit de censurer et de museler
comme ça mais à la fin nous gagnerons a
écrit l'ancien président donald trump
qui doit trouver de nouvelles formes de
communication et qui a fermé récemment
son blog
ce samedi c'est depuis la scène de la
convention républicaine de caroline du
nord qu'il pourra s'exprimer devant ses
partisans
un discours qui sera fermée à la presse